You now know the basics of dealing with NP-complete problems
or NP-hard problems if we're talking about an optimization problem.
Designing intelligent algorithms to find an exact solution, or, failing that,
accepting approximate solutions,
or even incorporating randomness into the algorithms.
Are those all of the possible ways that you can deal with an NP-complete problem?
Of course not; there are, for example, combinations between approximation
algorithms and randomization algorithms.
And, of course, there are also algorithms that you can use
if you don't demand performance guarantees because the algorithms
that we have analyzed, have always provided a certain guarantee
as to how they would perform.
If you don't require such performance guarantees,
there's an arsenal of other techniques out there, known as heuristics.
Some concrete examples for that would be evolutionary algorithms, genetic
algorithms, simulated annealing, local search, meta-heuristics, and many more.
Be warned, though; just because some other algorithms don't have any
provable performance guarantees doesn't necessarily mean
that they are simpler or easy.
Rather, successful implementations of any technique for an NP-complete problem
require a lot of thought.
And I think the general rule here is finding good solutions to hard problems
requires a lot of thought no matter what technique you're using.